البابا فرانسيس الآن خارج المستشفى
ويصلي بروح طيبة بعد
إصابته بالتهاب الشعب الهوائية هذا الأسبوع، وقد
عاد بالفعل إلى العمل، وتعلم سي إن إن أن
البابا سيترأس
احتفالات أسبوع الآلام،
وتنضم إلي مراسلة سي إن إن الفاتيكان ديليا غالاغر على
الهواء مباشرة الآن من روما، لذا ديليا  لقد
تحدثت بالفعل مع البابا أه كيف يفعل ما الذي
تحدثتم عنه جميعًا حسنًا، استمعوا
فيديريكا، فاجأنا البابا
لأنه كان يغادر في السيارة
من المستشفى وتوقف
وخرج ليشكر الصحفيين على
عملهم لذلك من الواضح أنني  سألته كيف كان
يشعر هذا ما قاله
إنه لا يزال على قيد الحياة ما
يتبادر إلى ذهني شيء
يريده رجل عجوز أكبر مني أخبرني
بعد موقف مثل هذا
الأب لم أرى الموت ولكن رأيته
قادمًا إنه قبيح هاه
أجنبي